the year is 2015 and space Sims are back
elite dangerous no man's sky star
citizen three games three galaxies three
fantastic reasons to get hyped for
hopping into your starship and exploring
the cosmos at a casual glance these
three games do all kind of look the same
though there's spaceships space combat
spacious cockpits and well space itself
ready to be explored unsurprisingly
these similarities have led to lots of
comparison and chat online over which is
the superior game but seeing as only
elite dangerous has actually seen a full
release to date no man's sky and star
citizen aren't due for space launch till
later on in 2015 and 2016 respectively
it's way too early to tell but now is
the perfect time to investigate what it
is that makes each game unique
new galaxies each one has its own to
explore but the way in which they are
made is perhaps the biggest difference
between these games the key is
procedural generation this is not random
rather a maths based approach to
building stuff the game literally
calculates what you see in encounter
based on complicated algorithms all
three games actually uses approach just
to different degrees there's a spectrum
if you like of procedural generation
at one extreme you find no man's sky the
entire game is procedurally generated
and as a result its enormous in fact to
all intents and purposes it may as well
be infinite in size with its billions of
unique explorable star systems and it's
not just space in one seamless motion
you can go from cruising the cosmos to
zipping along the planet's surface to
them walking boots down on the ground
everything you see the land the water
the wildlife it's all generated by the
powerful algorithms at the heart of the
game for more on exactly how this all
works check out my episode of reality
check all about it next to that on the
scale we have elite dangerous which is
equally vast essentially a life-size
copy of our own Milky Way galaxy was 400
billion explorable star systems again
this uses procedural generation for the
most part however is combined with some
handcrafted areas and what about star
citizen
well it's galaxy is going to be
significantly smaller I think they're
going for around 100 explorable systems
however these are all handcrafted by the
team so they're taking a quality over
quantity approach
a fair amount of what you can actually
do is similar across all three games you
can explore space hunt bounties trade
goods be a pirate and so on plus all
three have game worlds which react and
change depending on the player's actions
however star citizen distinguishes
itself here with the inclusion of
first-person shooting that's right as
well as a space sim it's a fully fledged
fps this means you can board derelict
ships star trek away team style and
salvage things are just generally wreck
up the place
no man Sky's gameplay has the addition
of discovering stuff find a new planet
satisfy your inner space naturalist and
classify the creatures which call it
home it's also the only one of these
three games which allows the player to
land and walk around anywhere in the
whole galaxy space can be lonely so
wanna explore it with friends both elite
and star citizen allow you to do this in
similar ways and elite all players to
play within the same universe however
when you approach an area say a space
station the game generates multiple
instances of this so if thousands of
people all decide to go to the same
station at once instead of being
chock-full of ships there will maybe be
just 30 or so people in your game no
man's sky however is taking a different
approach details are still to come but
it appears to be adopting a rare
encounter or journey esque approach to
multiplayer just without the singing
elite is incredibly scientifically
accurate even the space stations rotate
at the correct rate to generate the
appropriate level of gravity through
centripetal force to find out more
there's actually a whole episode of
reality check all about it so go check
that out
star citizen apps up the realism when it
comes to ship control modeling a physics
engine
meaning the tiny thrusters actually will
take correctly as you maneuver your
craft which is pretty sweet on top of
that you never actually leave your
character meaning you can walk around
inside your ship also the game has
anti-gravity movement and fighting to
finally how can you actually play these
games while all three will be available
unsurprisingly on PC but no man's sky is
confirmed as coming to ps4 as well
meaning it's the only one of the three
to have a definite console release all
three will probably support VR in some
shape or form elite and star citizen are
already compatible with the technology
an omen sky is very likely to support
both oculus rift and project Morpheus
and as T's as much in the past so that's
some of what sets these spacelings apart
in a nutshell do of course let me know
if you think I've missed anything
important by leaving a comment in the
box below or of course you can find me
on Twitter